okay once you're logged in
maybe i can start
okay uh this talk is all about fun with
uh web sockets
uh
this
uh approach to this talk is more
uh creative than well technical due to
the fact that i'm from a
creative
industry and my standpoint would be
always
to do something creative for
technologies like this
oops
okay
because my
uh
slide is a bit washed up
i am jp drivesman
from the philippines i've been in the
industry for about
13 years i've started when i was 15
years old fraud up of child labor
i was
yeah i was a flash animator then
and then started to progress towards the
server side i've worked with all sorts
of whatever
old-school technology that you might
think like asp
um is there any older
vb script and all of that i've been
through those kind of stuff uh work with
server side from java to php and then
now node
most of my investment of time would
involve php
okay and as what rico said
sorry
i am a founder of brain creative lab
brain creative lab is so
well we're a growing uh web design
agency we've been servicing
uh local clients we've we're so
fortunate that we've worked with
wonderful clients over the past years
and then again
just to set the tone of this
presentation it's all about being
creative
how i approach technology is not about
just plain code i need to communicate
something through
using whatever technology that we have
so let's go to the meat of the topic
which is well
fun with web sockets but for a very
simple definition i won't be using
uh
they say that web sockets by definition
is a bi-directional protocol using tcp
uh tcp
but you know it's it's a bit technical
for me and i don't want to use that kind
of stuff so let me say that
well websockets makes you
make crazy stuff in real time i'll be
simple with that because i think what
you can do with websockets is pretty
much make something wonderful in real
time
and
to limit my scope because there are
wonderful things that you can do with
websockets and one of the if you search
for
something about it the number one thing
that you would do is how do you do a
chat application through websocket but
my point there is will it always be like
that
i want to go beyond what you can do with
well socket programming and socket
communication
it's not all about chat chat is only a
gateway of
of stuff
thank you for that comment it's only a
gateway for you to move forward so i'm
going to discuss about multiscreen uh if
you would
be interested i have here three screens
that i have i have my mobile phone i
have my tablet and i have my computer
and you have
uh you've maybe you've connected to this
uh presentation
those are multi-screen application
now
let's go back to the fundamentals of
what the hell i'm going to be talking
about
i would call this patterns of
interaction
when they say patterns of interaction
it's it's really nothing new
it's about establishing how things are
being done for example how a message is
being communicated from its source
to its intended audience
basically
we use these patterns in order for us to
create something unique about
an application
it's hard to imagine real-time
application but understanding this
abstract patterns
now
i'm sorry for being watched uh for the
image being washed out but you can check
on the on the app on the second screen
application what the hell is is that
uh this is a one-to-one interaction
this is very basic i talk to you you get
back to me
simple
one-to-one is the fundamental of
any forms of communication
but what can you do with a one-to-one
thing what if you change the person
to a device suddenly things do change
suddenly possibilities opens up
so
my first encounter with
programming comes with this
game that we've joined for blackberry
it's realm of elysium we are so lucky
that we won the manila championship and
we're flown to bangkok for free
but we didn't win the competition
because blackberry is not interested in
games so it's okay
we use socket io in redis to build this
game
why socket io
if you want to realm of illusion is a
classic it's a twist on a classic game
battleship does anyone know game
battleship here
uh so everyone knows what the hell i'm
talking about
it's a two-player game
you guess my location of everything that
i have set up and then
once you identify all the location you
you win
my first encounter with socket io is
pretty much naive i thought that you can
just use the application and it will
work magically
then came the
the problems of
what if you access the application
outside of your comfort zone well sorry
and you're in a public wi-fi there are
certain ports that are not open and not
being open by certain security reasons
so this is the first time i've learned
that you can't do just use
port 8080 to your socket sakataio app
you need to use other parts such as what
i learned is using 443 it masked the
whole
protocol so that it would go into a
secured
somehow secured channel instead of you
using a different port
then
came this
application not really a wonderful app
but it what i call couch potato there's
one time that i i was watching tv and i
plugged my laptop into this big monitor
on my screen and i say it would be nice
if i can use my mobile phone to maybe
change the the video that i'm watching
because i'm watching youtube
and then came this this idea out of
laziness what if i have this remote
control and then i can select the video
that i want and then it will display on
my tv screen that would be wonderful
but
obviously it didn't push through but the
reincarnation will be in this uh
next topic another one would be the next
pattern another pattern is one to n
you everyone knows this as basic pub sub
you subscribe to a particular channel
and then every time something comes up
we publish and then you receive
but the question here is
what if i change those subscribers to
screens and devices
now you can start building screen relays
when i say screen lists i this is a very
cheap
idea that
you can combine multiple screen and then
produce a single uh display out of it
using this kind of
system and then another
application that i've done is this
platform hydra built just for this
conference uh i did
uh
take time to to build this so
hydra is the next best thing that
happened
aside from powerpoint so
it's a second screen sorry it's it's
only a joke uh
it's a second screen experience on what
you normally have when you're giving a
presentation because i can't write
everything here in my slide so i decided
why not just
send you the
other
supplemental content on your device if
you subscribe to this talk
basic cement
schema of how things is working i have
three devices
three things that's working here my
remote control my master slide the
subscriber and finally the server it's
using simple socket asap js as a
socket delivery delivery
platform and then everyone here just
subscribe to this channel and then you
get to have
the content that i'm streaming
okay
going back to another form of second
screen would be
this application uh has any one of you
managed to work with a second screen
application before i mean in in your
career
uh where you have your tv then something
stream to your mobile phone while
watching
uh chauvin's only one okay thank you uh
it's the first time in the philippines
that we've done this
uh tv5 is so ambitious that they can
deliver a second screen experience to
the masses uh the first
iteration of this idea was it should be
audio recognition so that when your
device suddenly hears a particular sound
signature it would stream content from a
particular server but due to our the
technical problems in broadcast where
you need to compress sound and white
noise seems to get caught during
compression we need to go and find other
solution that would work
then came the idea of uh
this this application
uh
sorry for again for the washout but how
it works is the tv is not really
a direct agent of the second screen
it's an indirect steam trigger in which
a broadcaster from the end of the
the process
manually pushes content so that when you
receive when when something happens in
in a scene you get to receive a message
in your device or in your ah yeah there
thank you thank you very much
so this is another form second screen
it doesn't really have to be i have
multiple screen
it can be a device in
a
totally indirect or direct screen that's
controlling certain
event to push
data
into your device
now i want to delve deeper on this
because this is a part of the
application that
we did struggle into how do you deploy
node application and scale it
horizontally
at first we've used uh
socket io running reddish
i i thought that i can just scale easily
because the the
the promise of socket io is this cool
they have this middleman approach with
redis that you can just plug it in but
the problem there is once you start
using it and putting it under a load
balancer which is nginx it started to
fail instead of switching between a
proper protocol which is a websocket it
goes to an xhr streaming which is really
nasty because you can't maintain state
if you're in an x xr
so
i cut it out and then revert
all the entire uh server into sock.js
and mind you it works
flawlessly um
we rely heavily on redis pub sub i did
try to use rabbitmq for message broker
so that if in case we scale out
horizontally and we need to cut redis
pub sub we can just migrate into a
different uh message broker uh type of
system
this is
for for some people i would say why
don't you use um express js or uh
existing
framework for node uh the problem here
is i've been
that my company has been investing so
much time with with php
so
sorry if you don't like php i'm okay
with that
what we've done is we just use node as a
relay server instead of using node as a
main application server
it gives us freedom to uh to decouple
services along the way uh we need to
integrate with several uh services here
we have the broadcaster that pushes the
data we have the grid that manages the
schedule a cms
in an actual api that connects
everything together
so that's how the application is uh
structured
next uh moving forward and
sorry
is an end-to-end pattern um end to end
is an extension
of your one is to end
everyone knows this but what if
everybody talks
this is the time where a subscriber
becomes a publisher as well so everyone
gets to communicate
uh
now the question there again is what if
we change this
uh
subscribers and publisher into devices
and let them talk to each other then
came this
idea
it's an interactive web comics
uh where
you need to hook 3d three or more device
in order for you to experience the whole
story of what we're trying to say
now in a normal comics you have a linear
type approach that one character leads
to another dialogue leads to another but
the question there is it's so flat and
linear what if you can read the comics
integrate another phone or device and
then get a different perspective from
your phone or if you have a tablet
integrate it and get another point of
view from that
and then another good thing there is
what if one character calls another
character then
each device can talk to each other so
imagine the possibility of bringing
different way of telling story
to this kind of uh
platform
well but wait
i would say there's more but the the
thing but wait there's challenges ahead
uh
how do you get to launch this type of
application
most of this
program that i always see in the in the
internet like youtube demoing this cool
web socket
technology are all in the comfort of
a local
system
it's really
hard to get this out of the door because
of various
uh issues that you would face when you
start uh using this i don't know if
someone of you has been encountering
problem while viewing this presentation
if yes it's totally fine yes it's still
in dev version
so how do you get this out of the door
is it just
uh just uploading it
we face a lot of issues here in in
building a real-time application one is
scaling
with dv5
oh sorry sorry sorry
going back with tv5 we don't really have
scaling issues
we only have what 200 users to serve and
you can also we can always build a mono
app that would house everything together
i don't need to worry about redis doing
pub sub i can just have everything into
one server but unfortunately due to our
circumstances
we need to think of a way to scale it
horizontally in making sure that they
can add a new node anytime that they
want so suddenly they're asking me can
you scale into a 10 000 user i say
i don't really know
we need to try it out
so
oops i was sorry i was disconnected here
but i can use my
laptop to
control that
a solution for scaling is always the
couple of service
you need to approach everything as in
there's a separate separation of concern
one is doing websocket one is doing the
application the processing you can never
put them into one application because
you want to limit you want to reduce the
failure if one services is out
everything will die down
so one solution there is decouple
everything
this should be a door is the the next
item here is
how do you
lure them in
you know with web sockets and things
like this
it's a magical experience that you see
things working and you know it's really
wonderful but the question there is
how far will your user invest time in
getting an appeal to that magic
the problem there is we as a developer
will always say in our discussion like
uh yeah try it out do this but when user
started using it suddenly it doesn't
work or suddenly users don't understand
the question you how do you lure them in
our strategy there is
well we just reduce the user time setup
experience
make them access a simple link and then
just go there have them feel the
experience
once they get into the application
there are lots of approaches here you
can use qr code you can use
sim
shortened url to to simplify all of this
experience
next would be connectivity
with mobile being so
stat i mean
uh
what's the term there
uh connectivity for mobile sometimes is
erratic you can never have a stable
connection so the question here is how
do you make sure that you have that
experience of continuous uh user
experience
okay if you are interested in want the
music there it's great piano concerto
so how do you
make sure that every the user gets to
have the transparent experience
it's
this
you need to provide a fail-safe protocol
switch
you can never assume that everyone will
have a websocket uh i was testing the
application here and i'm using the
default samsung browser unfortunately
samsung browser doesn't have websocket
supported so it switches to
another protocol in our tv5 application
uh if it's if the user has been cut into
the whole experience we need to revert
to a long polling uh
solution and sometimes a continuous
heartbeat to the server just to make
sure that they get
connectivity and data
throughout the whole experience
next would be
i think
i don't know anyone here still supported
ie6
okay
thank you
before
it's just ie6
now we have this
it's the number of browsers that we need
to support multiplied by the os
that we have
in the number of device
that people is using this is a formula
for insanity uh i don't know how
developer get into this mess but this is
the
number this is the figure that we're
looking at in doing such kind of
application and at one point in time
something will not work
it's just
it's just it
so
there you go
with everything that we have all the
issues that i've told you
my suggestion there is
just keep on trucking
because at one point in time you will
always find a solution for all of this
uh problem from the scaling part to
connectivity
to user experience everything has a
solution some of them might be a hack
some of them might be an elegant
solution but at some point time you will
find
something there okay
so my suggestion if you have an idea now
that involves websocket
things like that
just get on with it
forget about the risk that you would
take if you fail
to make it work just just try it out
again
i've shown you the three patterns
earlier
you need these are all
simplified in abstract nature you can
use this idea to come up with a totally
new uh
way of interacting you don't say
if you want to build
a complex websocket solution
you just won't say i need to do this and
do that no you need to look at this
interaction patterns and draft how you
would look into it
and then
you'll never know you'll discover
something new
then
finally
if there's one thing about this talk
that i want you to remember forget about
every all the example the problems that
i've told you if there's one thing
i it would be this uh websockets
let you make crazy stuff in real time
and
that ends my talk thank you very much
okay
uh
i think if
i think we can do a question
and for those who will ask
uh as a token for
your participation i'll be giving out
four
gifts
uh
for you to
ask me anything so if anyone has any
questions raise your hand starbucks and
two starbucks card that you can use now
loaded with 400 pesos so drink and
breakfast here
and then two thumbnails for the best
questions
that all right people would ask
so
we got prices for questions keep on
trucking
anyone
okay
sorry uh
someone raising your hands over here yep
someone
there at the back
okay hello sir
will hydra be open source i'm sorry will
hydra be open source
will hydra be open source
oh and that's tough
uh do you want it do you want a copy of
it
uh i can post it in in github um the
code might be so dirty uh i just built
it for about a week actually i was
coding it early this morning i just have
it uploaded so
uh
will hydra be open source i can uh have
it open source so that you can maybe use
it with your presentation and be as cool
as
as that and have a second screen
presentation uh sure
i'll just have it uploaded is that a
valid question for a starbucks card
listen we actually don't give okay you
probably don't give any
you know prizes for questions
totally to speakers just question
yeah if you want to give them two it's
also up to you
you're from anyone else with questions
you're from the physicians
anymore
i have three three items here
oh my no one's asking okay maybe you
want to ask him about uh his css
framework
uh can i ask that question
do i get a tumblr
i come in black
anymore
well okay otherwise maybe we find
somebody who's as cool as that
okay we have one question from simon
you get the tumbler
okay okay
that's a redis pub stuff um if you if
you miss data you're gonna lose stuff
right if they use the connection yes and
reconnect you're to miss data from the
pub sub how do you deal with that how do
you fill in the gaps okay
this is a good question on how we handle
data loss uh with rabbitmq you are
ensured that your message will still
stick if you use storage but for redis
how we do it is we've done how facebook
twitter does with their uh fan out
approach so when a user subscribe to a
channel
we put it in a
hash table of all the subscribe users so
that in an event a broadcaster sends a
new data it's being fanned out to all of
those uh
user table of all subscribed people then
what if the user is not connected
you switching a different protocol which
is a heartbeat what we use is we just
pull the data from redis of all the new
items that's been published and display
it uh that that's what you do to uh to
bridge the gap of the discrepancy for
using pub sub
i'm sorry
yes we need to do that because
in a fan out situation
you need to maintain what's new and
what's uh what's been
viewed by the user in in a span of the
whole
data when it was uh transferred
for 10 000 users that was all right that
was well that's that's a computational
expensive uh
approach right so
in order for us to handle that uh that
part my idea this is really
theoretical as of the moment but my
ideas there is to use what instagram has
been using for using rabbitmq
so you queue all the tasks for
particular nodes that available and then
produce a cursor of chunk
users and then process them one at a
time that would save you uh amount of
computation from looping from one to ten
thousand so if i need to uh do it in a
million uh all i have to do is to scale
horizontally and adding more nodes that
would process those uh those things
great thanks how big did you get as a
matter of interest okay number of users
it's so embarrassing we only managed to
hit with simulation i did produce a
simulator just to fake the whole
experience 500 it's really really small
but it gives
us the opportunity to
anticipate what problems would happen if
in case we reach to that certain uh
number
it's a hard problem
uh the problems it's a tough problem oh
yeah yeah um
i
didn't when i was doing this the the
second screen application i was blaming
myself what what mess did i get into
because uh at first i was naive that
it's very easy to do only uh do a normal
pub sub and then when load balancer and
all of this redis comes into play i was
crying almost at the verge of crying and
cursing myself what the hell am i doing
i should have been sleeping instead of
solving this kind of [ __ ] so developers
we get into that problem a lot except
the crying part
oh sorry you're a tumblr
so there you go
thank you all right is there anyone else
with a question i have two more
okay we have one question over here
hi uh i'm sorry uh i'm not really
familiar with the
web sockets but
can you just reconnect or resubscribe
the user
okay instead of
doing long polling or whatever ah
okay about reconnection in
switching protocols uh chrome
uh well the process here is is this how
socket io and how i do my reconnection
in and how i switch to a particular
protocol number one is i have a
connection threshold i have a
reconnection threshold
that would keep on connecting as much as
they can
until they managed to get a handshake
from the server
can you just reconnect are there cases
that your computer or your device would
somehow uh flip out and won't go with
socket uh
connection or in your load balancer it
won't switch protocol so that's that's a
number a
major problem that's really hard to to
predict uh once i've reached the
connection threshold that's the only
time i will show hey you've been
disconnected to the service
you might want to refresh your browser
to connect but for for
a brief period of time the user is not
seeing that so what i do if the user is
not connected the socket i put it in a
message queue
so that once the
uh the user is connected to the system i
just
pop process all the cues that has been
done and then
go on with it it's it's a
simple example of latency compensation i
think meteor
emily did discuss say that part but
that's what you do you need to do
latency and why don't you just force and
reconnect those are the problem there so
after i reached the threshold
i did need to switch on the
protocol because what what will happen
there is my client will say oh it's not
working again
so there you go
so i hope that i did i did answer your
question
from the philippines all right
okay so does anyone else have another
question we have one more place to give
away
and with the bag
can i ask a question
one last
one unless you were just stretching
right yeah
is there someone raising their hands
over there yeah yeah yeah okay
over there someone
uh here over here how do you see
websocket in the live streaming
video live streaming
uh
okay
uh what's your opinion on the on the
website in terms of live video live
streaming video live streaming okay i'm
not in the
uh i'm not an expert with uh video live
streaming um the only thing that i need
to be honest the only thing that i've
worked with websocket is just relaying
data uh on
in in this manner it's really
let's say elementary it's really a
matter of
how i construct the whole flow of data
to create this kind of experience but in
i think webrtc does this
this part
i have a friend that's experimenting on
on this one but it's very new uh in
terms of adapt uh
adoption of uh the technology but
how will websocket play into it i need
to be honest that i really have no idea
so
there thank you okay
all right so that will be all our
questions for jp thank you very much
guys thank you for
listening thank you